what's going on guys this is rob and it
is a beautiful day here in town it is
like 80 degrees here in Lexington and
I'm recording the street from my iphone
so like to begin in the end it may be
like like staring at the camera but
anyway so so a couple things one now
that I finally got back to getting an
iphone I can keep in touch with you guys
in real time on Twitter so I'm really
excited about that if you guys don't
know my twitter is as Marvel explained
so that's my Twitter handle yes just hit
me up there any time and I love being
able to talk to you guys and ask your
questions because you guys usually
always ask like what's your favorite
Marvel superhero and I'm like I don't
know but but yeah so I'm really excited
about that but the biggest reason why I
made this video is because I ran this
idea by like Benny and Sal and Dave and
my friends and family and all that they
all thought it was a really really cool
idea so given the fact that my channel
is rapidly approaching fifty thousand
subscribers my god thank you guys so
much I wanted to host a contest I wanted
to host a contest on who will have a
logo for my my hoodies and t-shirts
because I want to get into the process
of like having hoodies and t-shirts so
so here's the deal um send me a message
on YouTube I'm sorry a message at
t-shirts at Marvel explained calm and
that's a set an email that I've set up
specifically for this all right send me
your final mock-ups and me what it is
that you would be satisfied with having
on a t-shirt and hoodie now I'm going to
go through every single one of these I
don't care if there's a thousand of them
I don't care if there's 10,000 of them
i'm going to go through every single one
of them only send me one don't don't
send don't send me like five emails with
you know five different versions just
send me one so the one you send me be
sure that it's the one that you that you
want to go with but I'll go through them
all the winner will have their logo put
on my hoodies and t-shirts and I'll get
you something really good at comic-con
and you'll get a free hoodie and a free
t-shirt I'll just send it all off to you
at one time so so yeah that's pretty
much it I'm actually here at the mall so
I'm I'm gonna go shopping for shoes and
stuff and I'm spending all day today
hanging out with my sister
we're going to be getting together in a
little bit because it's her birthday
weekend so so yeah I'm pretty excited
about that but yeah so that's pretty
much it I'll catch you guys later peace